ich hab mir gedacht meine damen und
eigentlich den videos die leute geld
oder brechen den körper getan
diese vier videos durch die rating board
reck oder etwas schief mit weltrekord
ist auf jeden fall eine minute lang
zähne falsch rum putzen eine minute lang
für jeden fall schon wussten gar nicht
wie gar nichts ab sofort dafür die
kräfte und wie zur lehre fahrer in den
körper spannt sich ein schmerz wir haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am häufigsten sei es mit zucker
verwechseln in einer minute war alles
[Musik]
erfunden
oh mein gott du mit dem blog der
frühling perfekt abrunden
[Musik]
die meisten male ökologie sagen im 30
sekunden und es geht los
32 die meisten male einen karton
beleidigen ihren 30 sekunden
die meisten mal einen karton beleidigen
geht los in 32
pizza kartons offener kasten vorbei die
meisten kids aus dem luca - shop.de an
einer wand hängen haben schnellsten von
der new york new york westside laufen
mag verrichtet am schnellsten von der
ersten male eine lampen 30 sekunden an
und ausmachen weg lösen
32 die öftesten male kontraste
abonnieren und die abonnieren und 30
sekunden es geht los und drei war klar
[Musik]
347 2000 jahre später war die öftesten
male die nase rümpfen zehn sekunden 32
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die wenigsten male einen ballen zehn
sekunden hoch halten die häufigsten male
kiwi rückwärts sagen in zehn sekunden 32
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die meisten fußballs sind zehn sekunden
[Musik]
394 schweren verlusten
viele gemeinden fordern ist bei dem
video get high tech forum bereit zum
quartier um quartier vom mio ihr könnt
jetzt in einen kanal abonnieren oder
hier in meinem kopf stecken jetzt findet
jetzt für andere medien und berlin nach
unten könnt ihr auch die glocken klingen
dann bekommt die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]